We have a really great discussion forum for
more than 18000 of our viewers and listeners
on Reddit at David Packman dot com slash R
E D D.I. T. This morning I was checking out
some of the posts and user Mike Flight said
is social distancing like temporary dieting?
It seems like the current measures to flatten
the curve will work only as long as we all
continue to comply with them as soon as we
stop. Just like a weight loss diet, the curve
comes back. Reopening schools and in September
doesn't seem any different than reopening
schools in May unless the virus goes truly
extinct. The outbreaks will resume. Well,
listen, you're you're not wrong. There is
a question of how long are people going to
be willing to socially distance? I'll tell
you, I'm going crazy on just day four. And
it's because I want to be out there. I want
to be seeing people. I want to be doing all
my normal stuff. But we've got to take it
day by day and every day that we can continue.
We are flattening the curve more.
The idea is that by the time that schools
reopen, you will have some portion of the
population will have been infected and will
have fought it off.
And it is believed. I know there's these rumors
about re-infection. They don't appear scientifically
sound. It is believed that you are immune
for at least a year, if not far longer, if
you fight the virus off. Number two, there
will be treatments that will work. Number
three, the number of people who can spread
the disease will have been drastically reduced.
So, for example, in China, when they've started
to loosen, they are not seeing a resurgence.
They're being careful. To the extent we can
believe the data. So I agree.
The average American is not going to be willing
to self-quarantine for months and months and
months. And that's a problem. Wait is a race
against time. But early data, combined with
knowing more about how these things spread,
suggests that if people really behave for
I don't want to say how long. But it's gonna
be a little while. Hopefully we would not
see that relapse. And and remember, if this
does start to go down over the summer, there's
a chance that when the flu season comes back
in the fall, winter, that it's going to come
back anyway.
And the idea would be to be prepared for that.
This is exactly the type of stuff that that's
being looked at. So I share your concern generally,
but it does seem that countries that are getting
it under control, China, South Korea, as they
start to loosen, they are not seeing the relapse
infection so far. User paid in full. Says
David, should cell data, male t shirts. I
have news for you. Data. Male T-shirts are
now for sale. David Packman dot com slash
gear. This started bik. So this is like a
very inside nuance thing. A couple of years
ago I appeared on this black conservative
Jesse Lee Peterson's program and his big thing
is he calls liberal men Β beta males. This
is a whole alpha beta male thing that's become
very popular in some conservative circles
to talk about who's alpha, who's beta. And
jokingly, when we've been looking at, you
know, Bernie's path to the nomination or virus
spread or whatever. I've been joking and saying
data in the same way that Jesse Lee Peterson
says beta somebody on a stream said, David,
you're a data male. Somebody else said you
should make a t shirt. I made a call about
it. Design a data. Male t shirt. Data. Male
t shirts are now available at David Packman
dot com slash gear. And I ordered a sample.
I'll probably be wearing it next week. And
you can not. You can check that out.
But in the meantime, join the discussion at
David Packman dot com slash. Read it.